And No,
you know,
the evidence that are hierarchies of
competence.
Work is everywhere because everything
around us works all the time.
Are you on hers?
The Lee tells two interesting stories in
her book,
infidel,
which is a great book by the way.
Um,
she came from Africa and from a country
that wasn't very functional and when she
came to Holland she said there were two
things that really amazed her and this
really struck me because you know now,
and then you get lucky and you can see
the world you live in from an outsider's
perspective,
right?
You get to see through someone else's
eyes.
She said the first thing that knocked
her off her feet was waiting for a bus
in,
in Amsterdam,
and on the,
you know,
she's standing at the bus stop and
there's a pole there and there's digital
sign on the pole and the digital sign
says when the next bus is going to come
and counts down.
And then when it hits zero,
the bus appears.
And she,
she just,
she absolutely could not believe that
that would happen.
That there could be a sign that told you
when the bus would come and that it
would change and the bus would actually
appear and you think,
well,
yeah,
no,
that's a miracle,
man.
That's an absolute miracle.
It is.
You got to think that through,
you know,
the amount of timing and organization
and and and,
and reliability,
mechanical reliability and sociological
or social organization and dedication on
the part of the bus drivers in the
entire company and the organization of
the whole city and the state to make
that possible is absolutely beyond
belief,
especially when it's time to,
well perhaps not the second but to 10
seconds or something like that.
That is absolutely beyond belief and her
inability to comprehend.
That was the correct response.
And then the other things she was amazed
by was that you could go talk to
policemen and they would help you.
That was just,
that was just a no go for her because
for her,
her experience was policemen were there
to shake you down and,
and hurt you.
And so you think,
well,
you know,
I won't.
I won't dwell on that point any longer.
The point is,
is that it's absolutely ridiculous,
blind to make the assumption that the
hierarchies in functioning Western
democracies are fundamentally predicated
on power and tyranny.
And then,
you know,
I can use a biological example too,
which would place me outside of the
postmodern realm of argument because the
postmodernists don't believe in biology,
but,
but they act like they do because they
all die.
So,
so,
uh,
this primatologist named.
Well,
I'll tell you two stories.
Okay.
Because these are,
these are really useful.
So the ones about rats,
and I got this story from Jaak Panksepp
who is a great neuroscientists.
He wrote a book called an effect of
neuroscience,
which by the way is on my reading list
that's on my website.
It's a really good book,
affective neuroscience.
He's a great scientist.
He was one of the who he learned that he
learned that rats laugh.
They laugh out ultrasonically like bat.
So if you're going to take a look with a
pencil eraser,
they laugh,
but you have to record it and then slow
it down and then you can hear them and
you might think,
well,
rats laugh like who was creating the
grant for that?
What kind of idiocy is that?
It's like,
no,
no.
Just don't,
don't,
don't get ahead of yourself here.
You know,
he was showing that,
that that capacity for social
interaction,
for social interaction that was mediated
by physiological touch activated the
same,
excuse me,
activated the same circuits in rats,
but it doesn't people and that those are
actual biological circuits.
And we share them even with rats.
Now,
rats are quite similar to human beings.
As it turns out,
I could say especially postmodernists,
but I won't.
And uh,
and,
and so the fact that,
that,
you know,
that little rats giggle when you tickle
them is actually extraordinarily
important.
He also identified surprising.
I've been talking too much lately.
He also identified the primary place
circuit and mammals.
And that's a big deal too from a
scientific perspective.
That's like discovering a new continent,
like discovering a whole brain system
that people really didn't know existed.
That's a big deal.
So here's a little story about rats.
Young rats like to engage in rough and
tumble play,
especially juvenile males.
It's also the case for puppies.
If you've ever had a puppy,
dogs are like that.
They liked to wrestle and it's one of
the things that male human beings tend
to do with their offspring and it's a
really,
really good thing like rough and tumble
play with children really helps
socialize them because it helps them
figure out the difference between a
touch and even rough touch and pain,
you know,
because one of the things you're doing
when you're rough and tumble playing
with the little kid is,
you know,
you throw them up in the air and you're
wrestling around.
I built my,
I had two couches when my kids were
little that were sort of face to face.
So we built this little wrestling ring
and I used to go in there and pound them
half to death every night,
you know,
so they loved that.
I mean,
they,
they get so excited about that they love
that so much.
It's just crazy,
but the reason for that is like you're
stretching out their bodies and you're
showing them that they can't put their
thumb in your eye and you're teaching
them to be graceful and,
and,
and you're teaching them the difference
between something new that's happening
to the body and something painful.
You're really teaching them to dance and
it's this really complicated
physiological dance that that is
indicative of a socialized being.
That's partly why women like men who can
dance by the way because it seems shows
that you can pay attention to someone
else first of all,
that you're coordinated,
but even more importantly that you can
take the fact of your coordination and
coordinate that with someone else's
coordination.
So,
and that's very primal and
physiological.
It's built right into your body and
rough and tumble play helps with that a
lot.
Anyways,
rats also like to rough and tumble play
for much the same reasons and sort of
sort of pretty much all social mammals.
So you can tell that rats like it
because he,
uh,
how do you know if a rat like something?
Well,
he'll work for it and one of the ways
you can figure out if rat wants to work
for something is that no,
you get them in a state where maybe he's
desperate for whatever he's working for
and you can put a little spring on them
and figure out how hardy poles to go
somewhere.
He knows where he's going to get that.
And then you can measure the force that
he's willing to apply and that gives you
a rough estimate of his motivation.
Or maybe ask a bar,
press like a,
you know,
like a coke,
cocaine addicted rats to,
to receive the reward and you can count
rate of bar pressing and you can get an
estimate of how excited the route is to
go do whatever it is the rats going to
do.
And so panksepp used to put rats.
It pair them one riot against the other
in kind of a play arena.
Not a very big thing.
And uh,
and the,
these were juvenile males and they would
work to do that.
Okay.
So they liked it and then maybe one rat
was 10 percent bigger than the other.
And then when you paired them,
the big rat would beat the little rat
because 10 percent weight advantage was
enough to make the bigger dominant.
Okay.
So then they established basically
dominance and submission.
You might think about that as a power
relationship.
And to some degree it is,
but it's more complicated than that.
And this is very important.
So.
So the rats play together once and the,
a big rat pins the little rat really
very much like wrestling,
like rats wrestle just like people
wrestle.
And if you pair them together then the
big rat can pin the little rat.
Okay.
So now you've got dominant subordinate
rat roughly speaking.
And,
but then you see if you stop the
experiment there,
you'd think,
well the rats play to establish
dominance and submission.
But the thing is is that rats don't just
play once,
they play many,
many,
many times.
And that's also the case with human
beings is that you don't just play once,
you play many,
many times and there's a difference
between the rules of a game and the
rules of a set of games.
And that's so unbelievably important.
So you keep that in mind because we'll
return to that.
So anyways,
the next time the two rats get together,
the little rat has to ask the big rat to
play it because the rule basically is
subordinate entity asks dominant entity
to play.
And so the little rat does what mammals
do to play,
you know,
they kind of put their paws down and put
the rear end up,
bit up in the air.
You see dogs do that.
And unless you're completely clueless,
you know that,
that doesn't mean he's going for your
throat,
means he wants you to whack them on the
side of the head so he can sort of
pretend to bite you.
You know,
it's,
it's pretty obvious if you've played
with dogs and children.
So,
um,
yeah,
and I make that comparison because dogs
and children understand each other,
right?
They're pack animals.
They followed the same basic rules.
They know how to play.
They can become friends,
otherwise you wouldn't have them as
pets.
I mean the dogs,
not the children.
So anyways,
the little rat ass,
the big Rut to play big wrap things.
So yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll will play.
They wrestle and you pair them multiple
times.
Well if you pair the multiple times,
what you find is that less the big rat
lets the little rat win 30 percent of
the time the little rat won't ask the
big rat to play anymore and that you
think,
well who cares?
What?
Like why is that important?
It's like it's really important.
That's a really important discovery
because it shows you that that even rats
have a set set,
a sense of fair play that emerges across
iterated games.
It sits,
it's an.
It's evidence for the biological
instantiation of a social morality.
It's a big deal,
man.
That's a big discovery and,
and it shows you that even at the level
of rats,
they're very social animals by the way.
The interactions between rats,
her are mediated by something like a
sense of fairness or justice,
and so that's extremely cool because you
know,
we tend to think of animals as having
dominance hierarchies and that's
predicated on power and that idea,
even though the bloody postmodernists
don't believe in biology,
they extend that analogy up to human
beings.
It's just not true.